a couple of years ago my friend Destin
and I wanted to definitively answer the
question does water actually swirl the
opposite direction down the drain in the
other hemisphere at the time I was
living in Sydney Australia and Destin
was in Huntsville Alabama those are
about the same latitude just opposite
sides of the Equator so we created two
videos that were meant to be watched
simultaneously and if you want to
synchronize them yourself you can click
the link in the description but we also
recognized that that was a hassle for
some people particularly watching on
mobile devices and that's why I'm now
releasing this extra wide video of both
videos synchronized The Simpsons did a
whole episode based on toilets flushing
the opposite direction in Australia plus
other shows have supposedly demonstrated
this effect so I've seen documentaries
that seem to indicate that which
hemisphere you're in determines which
way the water is going to swirl but
there's this other group of people and
they seem really confident that it
doesn't matter where you're at the
water's gonna swirl however at once so
is this a real effect or not the
application of this principle to
draining water in Earth's two
hemispheres is just bunk but if you ever
just look for yourself and figured out
which way your toilet swirls if you try
it yourself you'll find inconsistent
results here in Alabama I've noticed
that some turned counterclockwise and
some go clockwise this sink sometimes
drains one way and sometimes the other
way you see most wellit's have little
jets in it so the swirl direction is
determined by the design of the toilet
and not which hemisphere you're in in
any container of water there's always
gonna be some rotation the water is not
perfectly still and it is this rather
than the hemisphere that determines
which way the water will swirl down the
drain so it's a myth crossing the
equator does not mean the toilets going
to change directions but what if we come
into the garage and do a more controlled
experiment but what if we could
eliminate all motion from the water this
is a 1 and a half meter kiddy pool I
have here a 5 foot wide kiddy pool
instead of filling the pool with no
vorticity at all I'm going against the
way it's supposed to drain so I'm trying
to fill it with the flow going clockwise
I actually filled the pool in the
anti-clockwise direction to be sure that
any clockwise motion we see is not due
to the way I filled the pool so let's
let the water settle for a complete day
so that we know this I've left this
water sitting here for 24 hours so it
seems like I've damped all of the
motions from the filling well I'm not
gonna reach in and pull a plug out
because that would induce some vorticity
I'm gonna use this valve that I have
connected to the bottom of the pool I
really hope this works
Destin wish me luck good luck there
I'm about to pull the plug okay opening
the valve in 3 2 1
watch it equality and the pool is
draining but you can't see any motion of
the water just yet if your water's been
flowing for a couple of minutes and I
haven't seen anything yet so we're gonna
put some dye in it to help us see where
the water is flowing I'm gonna put some
food coloring in on the four cardinal
directions around the pool
- now it's like a tornado went right off
the bat we got a counterclockwise
rotation we filled it up a clockwise and
now it's going counterclockwise you can
clearly see that the water is flowing
clockwise in this direction and that
makes sense because that's how it should
flow in the southern hemisphere due to
the Earth's rotation we have a kiddy
pool in my garage and the whole earth is
rotating and the waters going
counterclockwise because I'm in the
northern hemisphere it's real this is
real but you can see what a tiny little
effect it is and what extraordinary
lengths I have to go to to see this
effect so really you're not gonna see it
in the bathtub and you're not gonna see
it in a sink or in a toilet because
there are other sources of angular
momentum that totally wash out this
effect we just proved it because we just
eliminated variables the Coriolis effect
is really habit it works to understand
how it works
imagine a pool with one edge touching
the South Pole think about a pool near
the North Pole the pool is stationary
relative to earth but every day it's
actually completing one full revolution
the earth is spinning on its axis so the
pool spins around the pole once a day
now you can see the side of the pool
furthest from the pole travels much
farther every day than aside right next
to the pole the whole pool is moving but
the part that's closest to the equator
has more momentum and the part this
closest to the pole has less so the
outer side of the pool is moving fastest
towards the east and as you get closer
to the pole the velocity decreases down
to zero think about these velocities
relative to the drain in the middle now
imagine we drain the pool when we pull
the plug all the water starts moving
towards the middle water from the far
side is moving too fast relative to the
drain and so it gets out ahead whereas
water from near the pole is going too
slow and so it lags behind the side
nears the equator is going faster so
that water out runs the draining but the
water nears the pole is going slower so
it falls behind so when the water
approaches the drain it is swirl
counterclockwise
this is the reason hurricane swirled
counterclockwise in the northern
hemisphere and this is the reason
cyclones swirl clockwise in the southern
hemisphere the center of the hurricane
has lower pressure just like a drain so
the hurricane swirls just like our pool
the higher pressure air rushes into the
eye of the storm and just like in our
pool swirls in the direction dictated by
the Hemisphere and that's the truth
about toilet swirl
hey I hope you enjoyed that and thanks
for watching if you haven't subscribed
to smarter every day Destin's channel
yet then click here or if you want to
see his latest video click here and if
you're not subscribed to veritasium for
some reason you can do that by clicking
here or see my latest right here